madame monsieur bonjour il y à un mois
jour pour jour le monde tétanisé
incrédule regardez s'effondrer les deux
tours de manhattan symbole de la
toute-puissance américaine la suite on
la connaît l'amérique a commencé sa
riposte en bombardant pour la cinquième
journée consécutive des installations
terroristes et militaires de
l'afghanistan nous y reviendrons dans un
instant mais avant cela new york ses
habitants ont donc réappris à vivre
normalement même si une majorité d'entre
eux affirment que rien ne sera vraiment
plus comme avant sur les ruines des deux
bâtiments des ouvriers s'activent pour
tenter de dégager les gravats pour
tenter aussi de retrouver des traces de
ceux qui ont succombé près de 6000
personnes dont moins d'un millier ont pu
être clairement identifiés reportage
d'isabelle bechler tristan le bras
on peut voir le sud de manhattan comme
la fosse commune de près de 5000 humains
422 ont été retrouvés comme un
gigantesque chantier de recyclage qui
tournent 24 heures sur 24 ou encore
comme le lieu d'un crime jalousement
gardé par le fbi à chaque jour des
dizaines de milliers de tonnes de
matières sont soulevés tracts et
analysés par 2500 hommes et femmes si
motivés qu'ils négligent souvent de
déclarer des accidents du travail par
exemple un ouvrier a eu le pied écrasé
il ya 24 heures mais il a attendu pour
venir nous voir de peur d'être exclu du
chantier
l'atmosphère du site de ground zero et
très toxique à cause de l'amiante
utilisée dans la construction des tours
et des substances qui continue de brûler
il faut donc des contaminés
régulièrement hommes et véhicules avant
qu'il ne quitte la zone avec leur
chargement
avec la quantité de matériel qu'on
déplace en permanence on a constaté que
des poussières migrer en trop grande
quantité c'est ce que nous essayons
d'éviter le plus possible
à ce jour 218 mille tonnes de décombres
ont été extraites du site à part la siro
cyclable qui partent directement chez
les récupérateurs de métaux tout aboutit
dans cet immense décharge de flash qui
osent pour trie et analyse sous
supervision du fbi ait des centaines
d'ouvriers retourne tamisée value
numérote tout fragments qui pourraient
contribué de près ou de loin à l'
enquête policière ou technique
un pneu du train d'atterrissage
1 segment de carlingue et ses hublots
rappelle la violence effarante des
attentats rappelle aussi la présence des
humains qui ont perdu la vie le 11
septembre dernier parmi ces débris d'un
forme sur ce tapis roulant industriels
on cherche aussi leurs rêves en espérant
plus tard les identifier 4815 personnes
sont encore portées disparues
un mois après la tragédie